hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
today we're back on fortnight again and
we're gonna be talking about blitz the
new game mode that just got released
today and a few tips on how to win and
all that good stuff so let's get started
so blitz like I said is gonna be a new
game mode for fortnight it just got
added today on Monday I have no clue
what the exact end date is but I'm
assuming it will be going throughout the
entire week but it's a little bit
different from your normal fortnight
game and the reason why it's so unique
is because the storm is already in the
map and and the circle is already shown
when the game starts and as soon as the
bus leaves the storm starts to close in
immediately as instead of having a timer
in this game mode though you're gonna be
getting more material like wood brick
and metal and more weapons chests and
supply drops come more frequently
according to the actual notes which I'll
put on screen from for tonight Intel
there's a 20% increase on ammo boxes
spawning and a 30% increase on treasure
chest spawning as well supplier ops
descent time is going to be cut in half
from 60 seconds to I believe 30 seconds
and the max limit of a full bullets
match will roughly be about 15 minutes
since this is a squad only game-mode you
can grab a few friends and play together
fill your squad with random players or
do none of that and just do no fill and
play solo with the few extra teammates
it's entirely up to you and how ballsy
you feel like and what your skill rank
is so the first step just like normal
Battle Royale is to choose your landing
spot or in the gameplay shown the circle
was around places like tilted Pleasant
and salty to name a few like I said the
storm is already covering a little bit
so the corners roughly depending on what
your thing looked like mine covered up
jump Junction so I can't go there
obviously I wouldn't go there anyway
but other places like retail were out of
the circle so I wanted to stay within
the circle area I and the rest of my
team opted for Tilted which was a pretty
decent choice and tilt it was in the
middle of the circle for the entire
match sadly my top my team died pretty
early since I did a filled team with
just randoms but I managed to clutch out
and get about 6 or 7 kills of people
before I was eventually killed all I
killed out and I think I made it to top
5 for this gameplay you obviously want
to use your own tactics from playing
normal for tonight like harvesting
resources searching houses and doing all
that looting and other stuff like that
except you're going to have to cut your
time doing those and have since the
storm is faster in this game-mode you
won't have as much time as you normally
would
as soon as the bus leaves you have about
two minutes to get in the circle if you
want if you want to go to the places
outside
or grab a gun and harvest materials or
prepare for a fight the time around the
storm goes down by 30 seconds every time
so it's going to be starting at 2
minutes then 1 30 then in 1 minute and
then lastly at 30 seconds obviously
you're going to have time to loot and
stuff during the storm obviously the
storm will not just continuously rush
you throughout the whole time you're
going to get a bit of a grace period and
it happens to match the storm timer so a
full game of blitz is going to be 2
minutes of the storm rushing to the
circle a 2 minute grace period then a 1
minute in 30 second rushed to the circle
with the storm then a 1 30 grace period
then a 1 minute rush to the circle with
the storm then a 1 minute grace period
and then lastly is a 30 second rush of
the storm to the next circle which is
probably very small by this point and
then a 30 second grace period then the
30 seconds repeats so it's gonna go from
2 minutes to 1:30 to 1 minute to 30
seconds and then it repeats 30 seconds
until the game is over
for tips that I have any named area is
obviously going to be a good choice
since it has the most loot but do be
aware tons of people will be going along
with you in those areas if you do have a
preferred spot let's say factory in
between we're salty and retail is let's
say that factory happens to be in it and
that's kind of your go-to if you
definitely go there of course I'm not
telling you that you have to stick to
the named areas it's entirely up to you
but you obviously know the consequences
of going to those areas like in terms of
factory there's going to be a little bit
less loot but there's going to be less
people going as opposed to where you
would drop tilted where there's tons of
loot but tons of people are gonna go
there if the location you pick us around
the edges only grab loot from a few
places that you do have a limited time
and wait to find the next circle
continuously head towards the circle
while either grabbing loot or killing
players and grabbing their loot call it
to your teammates what's on the ground
so they can pick up the weapon and
continue moving you don't want to be
caught in the storm as it's going to be
even harder to escape because of the
fast timer prioritize what loot is most
important and continue running for the
circle like I said materials bullets all
that stuff you're just gonna be getting
as you just walk by but in terms of
whether there's a blue TAC or a green
pump just think really quickly because
you're not going to have a lot of time
to think so just grab what you think
you're gonna need and then get going
if you're like me and picked a location
in the middle you're job is going to be
just a little bit easier but not too
much you don't have to worry about
running far to get to the circle since
you're gonna be basically in the middle
the circle is going to be basically
moving around you and if you're out of
it you're only gonna be moving a couple
meters to get to the edge of the next
circle the only negative to doing this
though of course is that there's going
to be lots of other teams who have the
same mindset especially if tilted in the
game a lot of people are gonna be
dropping there so for me I like to go
l-shape when I start so that's just
personally me to grab a few weapons get
a few of the beds in the closets for
materials inside and then head on out
and start killing people and grabbing
their loot so like I said obviously you
want to grab a few weapons harvest a few
materials like normal but you should
mainly focus on other teams since this
will be mostly one of the more populated
areas especially if you're like me and
drop tilted when the game started so you
obviously want to keep in mind where all
their teams are dropping so you don't
get hit from behind or happy to get
sandwich and then it's game over another
tip I have is that you should really
only be harvesting material in the
beginning when you drop into one of
those named areas or wherever happen you
ever happen to drop because you're going
to be getting more materials from floor
loot and the buildings as well when you
start harvesting materials later in the
game will distract you get you caught in
the storm there's no real reason to
start harvesting trees while you're
running from the storm since you're
probably going to have tons of loot
depending on how many people you've
killed or how many things you've
destroyed I recommend destroying these
small little things like the closets the
beds the tables that stuff is going to
be giving you metal depending on what
you get but most of its going to be
giving you wood and since it's about one
or two hits you're gonna be getting lots
of stuff but very quickly and then my
last tip is to always watch the timer
normally you don't have to look at the
time or most the time since the timer is
very long but in blitz it's absolutely
crucial to check the clock as much as
possible if you don't check you can
become distracted and actually
accidentally get caught in the storm
because you were too busy looting a dead
body communicate with your team so that
everyone knows if the storm is coming or
not if you have another tip about the
Blitz mode that I didn't mention that
you feel is worth noting or worth
sharing it definitely put it in the
comments below I'd love to know so that
everyone can be caught up to date with
all their stuff and know how to win in
the Blitz game-mode just a quick recap
on the tips if you're dropping in an
area around the edge of the circle you
want to be grabbing a few materials
grabbing a few things as possible but
obviously it being somewhat stacked
obviously you don't want to have an
entire inventory full stuff and you
don't want to have like 900 wood you
just want to get the necessities and
then get moving to the center so you can
get into the circle faster if you're
like me and you draw
in the middle then your jobs like I said
a little bit easier you're gonna be
you're not going to be needing as many
materials since you're already mostly in
the circle weapons are going to be
plentiful but there's going to be lots
of teams dropping so you have to worry
about getting into a firefight and then
to recap my last two tips is to remember
to harvest materials in the beginning
because you're going to be getting lots
of stuff from the dead bodies depending
on how far you make it into the game and
all those stuff you're gonna be getting
that toward the mid and late game so
only harvest roughly during the
beginning and always check the timer for
the storm and that's about it guys like
I said if you have any more tips you'd
like to share it let them know in the
comments below and so that everybody
could be caught up to date on the Blitz
game-mode like the video if you did
enjoy I'm gonna start doing a lot of
these with these new event modes and
having a lot of fun with this mode
actually I'm playing this a lot I'll
gladly do more guides on the event new
event game modes whatever those happen
to be whenever they release I'll gladly
cover a little guide on those subscribe
if you're new like I said I'm covering
the guides for the new event modes I got
guides for new weapons whenever you know
how they happen to release weapons every
week I'm gonna start covering that type
of stuff as well as other general tips
and other guides on how to make people
better players since I've learned a lot
from fortnight and I'd like to share the
wealth with all of you my two most
recent for my videos are gonna be
on-screen if you guys did not check
those out highly recommend you do and
with that guys hope you have a great
rest your day and peace out enjoy the
new boots mode